once again
alec burks
guarding it from the start wiggins again
here's curry for the record it's good
but there it is
stefan curry
all-time three-point king in the nba
three-pointer
number 29.74
the man who changed the game
the igniter of the three-point
revolution of the nba
and now he stands alone at the top
of the three-point list
and you think about this
the way he changed the game it's almost
like how babe ruth changed baseball
with the long ball
he has changed the game
with the three-point ball how all 30
teams approach the game is because of
number
30.
and this is an absolute awesome
experience
to be able to witness to see
ray allen
and now
stephen curry and an emotional hug here
with his father dale curry
[Applause]
sawdell saw his mother sonja
bob mckillop his college coach
and davidson
is here as well the man standing right
next to coach mckillop is larry riley
he was the man who drafted stephen curry
as a member of the golden state warriors
what a moment this must be
and the degree of difficulty right
[Applause]
doesn't matter if you've got one two
three guys on them
alec burke closing quickly
a long three as curry
holds the record
there's sonia his mother in attendance
as well
[Music]
quick release
nothing but the bottom
[Music]
what a moment and here he comes
an embrace with ray allen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ray allen broke reggie miller's record
in 2011 it was february 10th
[Music]
and now stephen curry
breaks ray allen's record
[Applause]
tuesday december 14th
at madison square garden a 28-footer
stephen curry
the all-time
three-point champion here
in the nba
stay tuned as under armour pays tribute
to steph curry the best three-point
shooter in nba history
[Music]